[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen video in einem kanal
meine damen und herren ich wollte euch
eine kleinigkeit auf meinem leben
erzählen und zwar folgende situation die
ich selbst an seinem küchentisch es
müsli und plötzlich klingelte es an der
tür
ich bin natürlich dierking gesprintet
habe aufgemacht und dann stand da hack
zwischen activision aber ich meine
schaut euch das gespräch einfach selbst
an
hallo wir sind nun mal lieber wenn
mister activision okay und was ist los
noch bis zum 17
die black und biete auf xbox playstation
4 und pc
[Musik]
ok aber was hat das mit mir zu tun wir
wollen dich bei einem heftigen turnier
dabei haben bei was funktioniert am 20
oktober findet ein gaming turnieren
brandes noch ein call of duty black ops
4 in berlin stehst du dabei
also ich meine ich allein bei songs
hätten gaming zu mir dass das klingt
cool und das holz sie an dem mega event
an und ich glaube das wird man nicht
allein mitspielen müsste so dass wir
nein nicht du allein es kommen noch ganz
viele andere in pflanzen wie
beispielsweise masse gustav gab
max kreisrat max kann ich mit maximal 1
team wenn du dann am turnier teilnimmt
dann ja okay die verdammt jetzt kann ich
ja nicht selbst die hand gehen ja genau
so ein gespräch hatte ich gestern neben
viel spaß beiseite am zwölften oktober
kommt das neue black ops 4 aus und das
wird ein ziemlich geiles spiel und zum
launch des neuen call of duty wird ein
heftiges gaming turnier organisiert
daran nehmen viele andere influenza
youtuber aus komplett deutschland eine
unter anderem halt alle zerstört ihr
könnt bei diesem turnier übrigens auch
mitmachen wie das ganze allerdings
funktioniert und wir daran teilnehmen
können das erkläre ich euch gleich
nämlich erst mal ganz kurz zum spiel an
sich ich bin nämlich teil der hashtag
einem special des kampagne der beim
neuen call of duty black ops viel gibt
es zehn spezialisten mit verschiedenen
fähigkeiten
[Musik]
ich bin also der hier
der kurze und ich meine wir sehen auch
ehrlich gesagt eigentlich relativ
ähnlich aus
geschockt
alexander marx hat übrigens auch ein
eigenes spezialisten und zwar diesen
hier der heydt crash hoffentlich
kratzenberg für mich nicht beim du nie
da
[Musik]
wenn er also cod lied und bock haben mit
max und mir bei diesem turnier gegen
ganz wieder andere leute zu zocken dann
geht als allererstes auch die website
studio 71 dort kommen schrägstrich call
of duty dort findet ihr alle weitere
informationen könnt euch soll er in dem
drama das ist die microsite zu dieser
kampagne bode 2 gesagt wir machen müsste
es einen kommentar kunden ihnen die
unter dieses video he schreit herum hier
das passende mitglied wert für wachs und
mein team kommt in unser team und wir
werden gewinnen jetzt diese hashtags
nicht hinter den kommentare zu schreiben
damit wir deshalb probieren können und
dann nicht kommentare wenig mag trost da
plötzlich drin sonst kommt der luca und
mein team und wir werden gewinnen ich
drücke euch auf jeden fall beide daumen
hier beide daumen gedrückt dass sie
eines der 30 tickets gewinn für das
turnier in berlin am 20 10
also geht einfach auf die microsite dies
aber unter der beschreibung eingeblendet
und schreibt uns ein kommentar mit dem
hashtag warum ihr in max ich bin luca
hallo ich bin mal darum ihr in wachs
lässt sich hier der sind genetisch oder
so kommt in unserem team und bewerben
gewinnen um ihren wachsen und mein team
kostet mindestens 18 jahre alt sein
das spielzeug 18 und das gewinnspiel
endet schon am 20 also kommt in unser
team und wir werden gewinnen
[Musik]